welcome to this video lmll em okay let's
play mr. solitaria just do it like
Carlton oh but Alan it's not playing
stuff like g4 yeah yeah this is in fact
a move young I've seen it it's not the
kind of move that will be played in a
World Championship match but it is not
not that crazy with black teams
defaulters root g one so we get get some
sharp position out of this most solid of
openings yeah I don't I mean okay I'm
really just a very much classically
influence player and have a hard time
that to believe that this is any good
but now let's see
okay Michael Bishop f5 vs. can also just
take you and then play Bishop f5 later
okay he decides to take some pawn here
and give me a really a nice development
and we have efficient f5 also queen d 5
f-5 coming
I have serious doubts about all that
Bishop f5 now is playing what exactly
queen bee three years
yeah maybe
that's probably still an okay move I
wonder what i should do here I really
would like to play against this King
yeah but not not sure that I can do it
okay let's do something simple and not
for far behind on the clock that's the
main reason why you should why you can
do such a game where you're totally
comfortable that you that you just want
to try to refute it instantly what the
other guy is doing and then you get into
time pressure yeah of course I was
thinking that I have some ideas now this
Bishop d3d 393
okay and this is also a ticked ok take
here I can play Bishop d3 but this this
is answered by III okay let's take it
Joe not easy not easy to deplane
yeah that's not really it's not really
clear that at the end i will have
anything that i can play with should be
five rupees 7s toward annoying
check I can take b5 now but is it
helping me very much it's got Bishop g5
sheriff should you find him not not
really not really great
sure it's very not much that I can do
here probably
Don one time that's not good but i want
to i need to get rid of his rookie on
the same rank she's six shop here time I
can easily very easily get lost him this
this weird weird complications
yeah my Jack my bishops are kind of
loose oh that sets a nice tactic don't I
cannot even even avoid the immediate
medium here Jared was difficult it was
difficult I didn't have a didn't I
didn't have any any coordination really
I mean it wasn't any good for Wyatt of
course not but it was difficult it was
difficult rook c8 I have to go rook c8
maybe to get rid of the active rook
right here it is said is true key
already it is really trying this is more
active and yeah I had seen this one but
I wasn't that that's a cool move check
okay that's not possible in blitz I
cannot do that that was a clear way to a
draw and here I'm I'm already losing but
exactly this precise sequence angles I'm
losing exactly that that's the only one
losing Bishop before is a draw yeah yeah
he normally shouldn't even see the end
game after this crap to be honest but I
played it badly ninety force was really
relatively it was strong it was this is
the only playable move here
wise i go here and really crush him what
i can do is play 98 and this is much
better for black because I mean this is
a huge threat I'm threatening each oh
and I mean White's position is a total
mess here I'm far better centralized and
coordinated it's that was it was
probably that was the real thing that I
needed to do this was the only move
really saving white the ante was in this
weird complications where I lost the
thread iam okay thanks for watching